[Música]
tras una nueva jornada de marchas en
Francia contra la imposición de la
Reforma de las pensiones de macron se
registran choques entre la policía y
manifestantes que continúan en las
calles en rechazo a la iniciativa del
gobierno Tenemos reporte de París
Rusia y Ucrania extienden el acuerdo que
permite las exportaciones de grano por
el mar Negro la ONU y Turquía mediaron
en el pacto y confirmaron la
prolongación
Moscú tienen versiones distintas sobre
el nuevo plazo de vigencia
Donald Trump enciende las alarmas al
anunciar en su red social que según él
sería detenido el próximo martes y pedir
a sus seguidores que tomen las calles el
expresidente es investigado por el mal
uso de fondos de campaña para
presuntamente pagar por el silencio de
una actriz porno sin embargo no está
formalmente acusado
Buenas tardes Bienvenidos a las noticias
de Franz 24 en español Soy Rosa Pérez
más deu y es para mí un gusto
acompañarles abrimos esta edición en
Francia porque tras una nueva jornada de
protestas convocada por los sindicatos a
esta hora la policía antidisturbios ha
dispersado a los manifestantes en las
calles de París que protestaban contra
la imposición de la impopular Reforma de
las pensiones recordemos que la mayoría
de la sociedad francesa ya se oponía a
la reforma pensional de macron y había
salido a las Calles contra la propuesta
de ley sin embargo la indignación volvió
a estallar el jueves después de la
decisión del presidente de forzar la
aprobación de la Reforma sin votación en
la asamblea nacional desde la capital
francesa Luis Miguel Cabrera con los
detalles
otra jornada de movilizaciones masivas
en todo el país después de la aprobación
por la fuerza de la Reforma de pensiones
propuesta por el presidente Emmanuel
macron aquí en la plaza de Italia hemos
conversado con varias personas que nos
llamaban la atención sobre su
indignación y su determinación en
detener a este gobierno que crea un mal
precedente al aprobar una iniciativa
suya opuesta a la voluntad popular y
también a la representación en la
asamblea nacional nos comentaban que hoy
este gobierno ha cambiado la edad de
jubilación de los ciudadanos franceses
pero mañana si queda impune esta acción
suya pudiera derrumbar otras conquistas
sociales del pueblo francés otras
personas nos comentaban que le desde nos
veían más bien La parte positiva de la
aprobación la utilización de ese recurso
constitucional porque ha catalizado
realmente el movimiento popular que en
la última semana se apreció con un poco
de desgaste porque han pasado Ya dos
meses desde el inicio de las
manifestaciones por lo que hemos podido
apreciar aquí si también tenemos en
cuenta las en todo el territorio francés
pudiéramos estar a las puertas de un
potencial estallido social en Francia y
este sábado que Moscú gracias a la
mediación de Turquía y de la ONU
acordaron prolongar el acuerdo que
permite exportar granos desde los
puertos del mar Negro Aunque el nuevo
plazo de vigencia no está claro el
acuerdo expiraba Esta media noche y
según Rusia se ha prorrogado por 60 días
mientras que Ucrania aseguró que por los
próximos cuatro meses
un carguero lleno de trigo cruza el
bósforo una transacción posible gracias
al acuerdo firmado por rusos y
ucranianos el pasado mes de julio este
compromiso conocido como la iniciativa
del mar Negro ha permitido exportar
desde Ucrania más de 24 millones de
toneladas de cereales
exportaciones vitales para aliviar la
crisis alimentaria mundial
es extremadamente importante que la
iniciativa del mar Negro siga
funcionando no solo para continuar el
comercio eficiente del grano a través
del mar Negro hoy sino también para la
próxima cosecha y la próxima temporada
Necesitamos poder seguir teniendo el
flujo de grano necesario para
estabilizar el mercado
Moscú propuso prorrogar el acuerdo dos
meses más el texto original firmado bajo
los auspicios de Turquía permitía una
prórroga de 120 días sin embargo desde
las partes mediadoras no se ha
especificado la duración de la
ampliación del acuerdo Aunque Ucrania
sostiene que es por cuatro meses y Rusia
por dos
negociación Rusia negocia para obtener
facilidades para sus propias
exportaciones
Por otra parte Rusia no quiere que se
considere que bloquea las exportaciones
de los países al sur que necesitan esos
cereales
una segunda parte de la iniciativa se
refería a las exportaciones de
fertilizantes antes de la guerra y las
sanciones
Moscú enviaba fertilizantes a todo el
mundo hoy más de 260.000 toneladas de
fertilizante rusos están bloqueadas en
los puertos europeos al kremlin le
gustaría poder reanudar este comercio
con normalidad a pesar de las sanciones
económicas las autoridades ucranianas
agradecieron el sábado a las Naciones
Unidas y a Turquía la prórroga del
acuerdo de granos
el lunes se cumplen 20 años desde el
comienzo de la invasión ilegal de Irak
liderada por Estados Unidos y rechazada
por la ONU la administración Bush
recordemos argumentó la ofensiva con
evidencias falsas de supuestas armas de
destrucción masiva en manos de Sadam
hussein Y si bien la guerra para
derrocar al presidente iraquí duró menos
de un mes la violencia continuó durante
años los civiles muertos se cuentan por
decenas de miles y la invasión fue
determinante en la desestabilización de
la región dos décadas después la
situación en Bagdad ha cambiado y los
jóvenes viven otra cara de la capital la
historia es de nuestra enviada especial
Catalina Gómez Ángel
Esta es una imagen que pocos imaginarían
de una ciudad como Bagdad una ciudad que
en el imaginario colectivo de todos está
en guerra y la realidad es que lo ha
estado especialmente rodeada por
violencia durante años no solamente
desde la invasión de los americanos en
el 2003 sino que ya vivía con mucha
violencia durante la época del excitador
Sadam hussein y es interesante Porque
muchos de los jóvenes mayores de 20 años
que están esta tarde aquí nunca en su
vida se plantearon tener un concierto al
aire libre con jóvenes reunidos
especialmente mujeres y hombres
todos los días habían bombas en cada
ciudad la gente sólo podía ir a trabajar
no es como se ve Ahora nada como ahora
como niño no pude jugar a nada Solo
íbamos al colegio y regresábamos a casa
Yo solía vivir en mosul Así que fui
Testigo Del estado islámico vivimos allí
por seis meses cuando Ellos tenían el
control de musul fue muy duro pero
escapamos tuvimos suerte
los jóvenes que tienen Entre 10 y 15
años no conocieron la violencia sectaria
tampoco recuerdan a los norteamericanos
en las calles y mucho menos la presencia
de Sadam cuando todavía era dictador del
país lo poco que han vivido ha sido
Durante los años de Isis cuando tomó al
menos el 40% del país para ellos no es
tan inusual encontrarse en un lugar como
este algo totalmente diferente a lo que
ven los mayores que tal vez nunca
pensaron vivir un momento como este
pienso que todavía necesitamos más más
gente que entienda el concepto de
libertad que está bien celebrar Aunque
Todavía no es seguro para las mujeres
en Estados Unidos el expresidente Donald
Trump vuelve a estar en el centro de la
actualidad Y es que después de regresar
a Facebook y YouTube publicó en su red
social Truth social que una filtración
le informó que será arrestado el martes
por los pagos con fondos de la campaña
de 2016 a la actriz porno stormy Daniels
a cambio de su silencio y animó además a
sus seguidores a protestar contra la
detención y a recuperar la nación Luis
Muñoz con los detalles
tormenta Trump el expresidente dijo en
su red social red social que podría ser
arrestado el martes un mensaje que
recordó al que precedió al asalto al
Capitolio ahora filtraciones ilegales de
una corrupta y altamente politizada
oficina del fiscal de Manhattan que ha
permitido que se establezcan nuevos
récords de crímenes violentos y cuyo
líder está financiado por George soros
indican que sin que se pueda aprobar
ningún Crimen y basándose en un viejo y
totalmente desacreditado por numerosos
otros Fiscales Cuento de hadas el
candidato republicano más importante y
el expresidente de los Estados Unidos de
América será arrestado el martes de la
próxima semana protestas recuperen
nuestra nación un gran Jurado de Nueva
York que Investiga los presuntos pagos
de Trump durante la campaña de 2016 para
silenciar a la actriz porno estormy
Daniels y a la modelo de Playboy Karen
mcdual por un total de 280 mil dólares
pagos registrados como gastos legales
sería el primer ex presidente en ser
acusado de un delito esto podría afectar
carrera presidencial
el Cardo que puede presentar El fiscal y
que parece que está a punto de presentar
es que Trump falsificó los registros
comerciales de la organización Trump lo
cual es criminal en Nueva York si
falsifica los registros comerciales de
una empresa comercial Entonces está
sujeto a una sanción de al menos seis
meses eso es un delito menor pero si lo
hace para ocultar otro delito Entonces
se convierte en un delito grave y eso
puede darte una sentencia de hasta 4
años que es un impacto mucho mayor
Trump también enfrenta investigaciones
criminales en Atlanta y Washington por
sus esfuerzos para revertir los
resultados en 2020 también se investigan
los documentos clasificados encontrados
en el domicilio del ex mandatario en
Florida
y miembros del tribunal internacional de
los derechos de la naturaleza demandan
que se detenga el proceso del tren maya
en la Península de Yucatán en el sureste
de México porque deforestación de la
selva contaminación del agua despojo y
expropiación de las tierras es parte de
lo que han enfrentado comunidades mayas
desde que comenzaron las obras del
proyecto insignia del presidente Andrés
Manuel López Obrador
Nelly Lleva más de 30 años dedicada a la
apicultura y es la primera vez que las
abejas no están siendo productivas no
hay duda las colonias están sufriendo
los efectos de la deforestación
ocasionada por la construcción del tren
maya en la selva de la Península de
Yucatán en el sureste mexicano qué es lo
que observamos las abejas tienen una
situación de yo les digo que están
desnutridas no tienen el mismo nutriente
no tiene la misma fuerza no tienen la
misma
Vamos a decir que la energía para
reproducirse desde su inicio el tren
Maya ha enfrentado más de 25 amparos de
asociaciones y organismos del medio
ambiente que buscan la suspensión de la
obra uno de los tramos más polémicos es
el cinco ubicado entre Tulum y Playa del
Carmen en el Estado Sureño de Quintana
Roo porque atraviesa y amenaza largos
tramos de Selva virgen que han sido
deforestados sistemas de Cuevas que se
han derrumbado con las maquinarias y
flujos hídricos que han sido alterados
he visto cenotes
donde estamos ahora
está condenado está moribundo
va a morir no hemos fallado en salvarlo
la selva que quitaron de aquí la selva
que yo conocí que estaba arriba de este
cenote ya no está pues es del tribunal
internacional de los derechos de la
naturaleza constataron las violaciones
al medio ambiente y notaron la
afectación a cientos de especies que
viven aquí la selva maya
como que agoniza como que
dice pide auxilio pide auxilio al mundo
a los ecologistas a la comunidad
científica que intervenga y a las Cortes
internacionales para decir que pare esto
el gobierno de México con este proyecto
insignia intenta construir 1.550
kilómetros de vía de ferrocarril a
través de cinco estados del sureste del
país y su meta es inaugurarlo en
diciembre de 2023 desde grandes
depredadores como el jaguar Hasta los
más pequeños como las abejas están
resintiendo el atropello del tren que
aún no pasa pero que ya deja sentir sus
efectos y cerramos en Chile porque el
gobierno de Gabriel boric vuelve a tener
sobre la mesa el tema de los indultos a
12 personas condenadas por sus acciones
durante el estallido social de 2019 Y es
que salió a la luz un informe de las
autoridades penitenciarias que habían
recomendado no otorgar estos beneficios
a seis de los 12 detenidos cabe que en
su momento por este caso tuvo que
dimitirla entonces ministra de justicia
y el jefe de gabinete de borich nuestra
corresponsal en Chile Patricia Luna nos
amplia
Pues los informes de gendarmería que
fueron difundados por un medio
informaban de que seis de estas personas
indultadas Tenían un riesgo alto o muy
alto de volver a reincidir y que tenían
poca conciencia de los delitos cometidos
y por eso advertían en contra de esos
indultos el tema vuelve sobre la mesa al
gobierno de Gabriel borich que ha
evitado referirse a él por cuestionado
el viernes y dijo que toda la
información está ahora en el tribunal
constitucional en la misma línea se
manifestó el ministro de Justicia Luis
Cordero que dijo que no se puede referir
a estos antecedentes puesto que están
por el en el tribunal constitucional que
está viendo como pidió la oposición si
estos indultos pueden declararse o no
inconstitucionales Además la polémica se
Aviva porque también Se confirmó un
nuevo indulto en trámite la oposición
Pide a la cámara de diputados que active
la comisión de investigación sin
relación puesto que ya lleva unos meses
desde que se solicitó y que investiguen
si estos esta medida podría llevar o no
en algunos casos algunos de ellos
especialmente de sectores como
renovación nacional hablan también de la
posibilidad de presentar una demanda de
inconstitucionalidad una demanda de
constitucionalidad también contra el
presidente llegamos así al final de esta
edición pero sigan con más información
en France 24 y 24 punto com
[Música]